good afternoon everybody thank you so
much for coming my name is Kimberly gray
and I work with dr. David door and he
wasn't able to make it today and so I'm
going to introduce his intern for him
was going to be the first intern
presenting today it's my great honor to
introduce you to Rochelle McDaniels
Rochelle is a sophomore and she is
currently in the Western Oregon
University Honors Program she hails from
the clackamas Portland area and
currently she's majoring in biology but
when I was talking with her this morning
she said that working with this program
has given her aspirations to be a doctor
how we will see where that goes and
looking forward to a presentation Thank
You Kim I don't know can you guys hear
me is this on okay all right so like Kim
said I'm Rachelle McDaniel and I worked
with dr. David door and very closely
with Kim on a project this summer that
dealt with measuring patient of
experience or measuring patient
experience as an indicator primary care
quality through the cap survey I've
literally been referring to it as my
capstone project all summer I'd you
thought that was funny all right so a
little overview of my presentation I'm
first going to talk about why primary
care is important then I'll introduce
you to PCB CH caps top med in our
research study i'll talk to you about my
actual role in the project i'll share
with you the results important findings
from those results and some conclusions
that we can make from them so first of
all why is primary care so important why
do we have to keep improving it primary
care is the primary care is the first
step it's the first point of contact for
all patients in the healthcare system
primary care physicians are responsible
for doing preventative care for managing
chronic illnesses it's essentially what
keeps our population healthy so now that
we can move on so how do we improve it
we are using a model called PCP ch
it is stands for patient centered
primary care home it's a model in which
you know like the name suggests the
patient is at the center of their health
care team health care team is held to
high standards two of these standards
here being comprehensive continuous
accessible accountable coordinated and
patient and family-centered care in
order to give the best care possible and
in doing so it this model attempts to
improve the Triple Aim of primary care
which includes the quality of patient
care the overall population health and
cost effectiveness so how do we measure
it what we used the cap survey it stands
for consumer assessment of healthcare
providers and systems and it is actually
a patient experience survey rather than
a patient satisfaction survey and they
may sound like the same thing but I'll
give you a quick story as to why it's
not the same thing so this guy here he's
in pretty bad shape so if you asked him
won't already satisfied with your health
in your health care he probably wouldn't
give the highest rating and you wouldn't
know why he would be would just know
that he gave a low rating so with
patient experience it measures patient
satisfaction in multiple areas so you
have a better idea of where exactly the
improvements need debate instead of
blindly trying to improve primary care
um in the cap six survey or measures
patient experience in these eleven areas
I'm not going to read all of them off
just know that I'm going to refer to
specific ones later on so now that we
have our measuring tool we are I'm going
to talk to you about our actual research
study so top med stands for transforming
outcomes for patients through medical
home evaluation and redesign it's a
cluster randomized trial and so for the
study we surveyed or we sent out surveys
to eight hundred patients 100 from each
clinic and during a pre and a post
period of each of the hundred patients
50 were high-risk patients in
if you were lowest patient high-risk
simply means they're more at risk I have
a higher tendency to be hospitalized for
various reasons like chronic chronic
illnesses or age and other factors we
had of the eight clinics we had four
that were control and for that were
intervention the main difference between
the two is that the intervention clinics
were taught to focus on high-value
elements after the pre period and before
the post period so we'll be measuring to
see if focusing on high-value elements
really improves the quality of primary
care and patient experiences as so
before I read off the hypotheses I want
to talk to you about a term that we'll
be using a lot percent positive response
scores and this is simply the percentage
of patients that answer the most
positively on any given question overall
the patients that answer that question
and all together and then each of those
percent positive scores are combined and
waited into a total composite score for
that particular area of the cap survey
that I showed you earlier there were 11
of them all right and so we had four
hypotheses for this study but I'm only
going to talk about two that's all I
have time for today in this first one
states that they post study percent
positive response scores will be higher
than the pre-study percent positive
response course so in general scores
will go up everyone's going to be much
happier with their care all across the
board and the second hypothesis is that
the change in intervention scores will
be larger than the change in control
scores ie the intervention clinic scores
will increase more than the control
clinics so now we get to my project and
my roles in this so the first thing we
did was finishing the post data
collection just so you have a quick
summary of how we collected the data we
would send out mailed so we would mail
out surveys to eight hundred patients if
they didn't respond then we would give
them a phone call and see if they would
like to still respond or not and if they
still didn't respond to the phone call
that I make them then we
send them another when you send them
another survey in in order to get the
response rate that we want I felt like
this a lot in the phone calls all right
and then after we had all of the surveys
I would map the answers that were given
two numbers and insert them into the
database using the Likert method give
you a quick example here's one of the
questions from the cap survey if a
patient answered excellent on this
question then I would insert one into
the database and that would make it much
easier to see the percent positive score
and then afterwards after all the
calculations were done I would analyze
and try to make sense of the data okay
so before I could look at the caps data
and all the composite scores and try to
see if there was a difference if there
was a change or anything like that I
looked at the responses like the number
of respondents versus non-respondents
and if there was any sort of bias
between like if they were high risk for
low risk if they were a part of the
controller intervention if gender age
all of those categories so this can be a
little hard to see if there is any
biases just based on this graph here so
instead I did pi square calculations
comparing the respondent versus
non-respondents in each of these
categories which are high risk low risk
control intervention gender age and race
so after doing the chi-square
calculation you will get a p-value and
if it is less than 0.05 which is the
convention then it's considered to be
statistically significant so for control
an intervention gender and race there
was no bias in whether they would
respond or not so that wasn't something
that we have to take into account in the
later analysis but for high-risk and
low-risk in age there was actually quite
a bit of bias high-risk patients tended
to respond more than low-risk patients
and elderly patients tended to respond
more than younger patients so this is
just something that I'll have to keep in
mind
looking at the caps answers later
because these will be the people that
were actually the opinions were actually
measuring so I also looked at the
response rate by taking the number that
actually responded and dividing by the
expected and the expected was the total
number of people or the total number of
surveys we sent out taking and minus
thing the patients that we excluded for
various reasons and for the pre a
response rate for the priest Eddie was
forty five point five five percent and
the response rate for the post study was
forty two point seven five so it's a
little bit lower we'll just I'll have to
keep that in mind as we move on so the
actual big analysis that we did was a
difference in difference to see the
differences between the change in
control and change an intervention
percent positive scores over time so the
best way that I like to explain it is
using a series of graphs so first I
would find the difference between the
pre and post scores of control for each
of the eleven caps composite areas and
then the same for the intervention so
then we would have our change in control
and change an intervention and then we
are going to next find the difference
between these two differences hence
difference in difference so take the
intervention and you minus take the
change in intervention minus the change
in control and you have the final
difference in difference analysis force
so this is a lot of data you can see
that for some caps areas like three and
five that they increased a lot so that
means the change in intervention scores
were quite higher than they change in
control and then for those two negative
scores up there that means the change in
control was higher than the change and
intervention which is the exact opposite
of what we predicted would happen and
you might be wondering what all of those
little symbols are there to indicate
whether it's statistically significant
or not so because it really doesn't mean
anything unless we can say it's Stickley
significant
so the if it has a star at the caps area
has a star on it then it means it is
statistically significant but for the
difference in difference between control
and intervention and pre and post if it
as a heart it's statistically
significant for the difference in
difference between high-risk and
low-risk and pre and post and so the
three areas where it's just really
significant for the control and
intervention are 3 5 & 6 which is follow
up on test results patients rating a
provider or doctor and providers paying
attention to your mental or emotional
health and ones that are statistically
significant for high-risk and low-risk
are 5 6 and 7 which is again patients
creating a provider or doctor providers
paying attention to your mental or
emotional health and provider support
you and taking care of your own health
so this is a lot of information what
exactly can we draw what's the most
important information so I'm just going
to reiterate the important findings that
we found with this data first we had a
lower response rate in the post period
that we did in the pre period this isn't
exactly what we expected to happen we
expected there to be more of a response
rate we expected we also expected there
to be a more positive response rate but
instead this scores decreased over time
which meant they were lower the second
time around and we change an
intervention clinic scores over time
we're generally higher than the change
in control which actually does match our
second hypothesis it does support it and
we had some areas that had some very
large changes ones that are the most
most notable 3 5 and 11 with three
increasing 16.7 % 5 increasing 13.5
percent and access to care decreasing
12.4 percent this is probably one of the
most surprising results that we've had
so far and will need a we need an
explanation to figure out why and the
three statistically significant
differences for the difference in
rinse we had again areas three five and
six and they had less than with a
p-value of less than 0 point one and we
had a p-value of less than 0 point one
for these instead of less than 0 point 0
5 because there's extra variability in
trying to measure human opinion
essentially on these through these
surveys so why might be have happened
some people might have said that we just
got an angry or group a second time
around but I think that it might be more
attributed to one of the recent health
care reforms very recently we had
thousands more patients added on to
Medicaid so that would make so that
means the primary care provider suddenly
have to make room and try to take care
of thousands of more patients so that
would significantly decrease your access
to care for patients I can't get in when
they want because they're competing for
a spot essentially with a lot of other
patients and so why would only that area
decrease and nothing else like you would
think they would be more angry at their
doctors because they can't get into
seeing them but that's actually not the
case when I've talked to patients over
the phone they were all actually they
loved their doctors it just didn't like
the health care system they were
frustrated that they couldn't get in
they couldn't get the test done that
they needed to their backs hurt so they
couldn't it was just a lot of various
reasons but they all love their doctors
I thought their doctors were wonderful
people so that would be why only certain
areas like access to care which isn't
really controlled by the doctors as much
as the people in charge of the doctors
like your health care your government in
your health care system and why patients
provide rating of a provider doctor
wouldn't decrease now it actually
increased significantly which I actually
attribute to the like we said before the
focusing on high-value elements in the
intervention clinics I think it actually
does make them seem like they're really
focused on the patient and it therefore
makes the patient feel better about
their care and they will then have
better positive scores
alright one last I'm going to talk a
little bit about specifically high-risk
and low-risk and the findings that we
had with them we found that high-risk
patients were more likely to respond the
lowest patients for both the pre and the
post study if you remember that far back
we also found that high-risk patients
tended to give higher ratings than
low-risk patients for both the pre in
the post study we have these
statistically significant areas five six
and seven in which the response was it
was obvious that the high-risk patients
were like we're rating more positively
than low risk so why would this happen
something what we did not expect at all
was that the high-risk patients were
responding more than lowers patients
before we did anything during the post
during the procession we were expecting
there to be a big change with this
implementation of the high-value
elements in the intervention clinic most
of the high-value elements are focused
on high-risk patients and developing
care for high-risk patients more so why
would so why would high-risk patients
which are in bad health be more happy
with their health care before we did
anything about it so I actually
developed a theory based on just talking
with patients and seeing the little side
notes on their surveys when they were
mailed in that I like to call the
presumption of health theory and it's
essentially you're pursuing to be
healthy and tell you are proven sick and
I like the judicial system so it takes a
lot of okay diagnosis to make care
easier with high-risk patients have a
diagnosis already so it makes their care
very easy for doctors because when you
have a diagnosis you have a
straightforward set of instructions on
how to treat them you know exactly what
you have to do have to give X medicine
and why amounts for the amount of time
to this patient it makes its easier on
the doctors to give care to high-risk
patients who already have a diagnosis
and lowers patients which tend to be
healthy and so they don't really have a
diagnosis of a serious illness or
anything are considered to be just that
just healthy and if they come in with
symptoms of like a cold it's assumed to
be a cold because they don't have that
much time and energy to investigate all
of the different symptoms that come in
or all the different patients that come
in to see them so and the real problem
is when the healthy patients are
presumed to be healthy but are actually
sick and so they feel like they have to
be their own doctor they have to really
push to get the tests that they need
done we really have to be their own
healthcare advocate this is a lot of
patients that told me that that's what
they found the most frustrating over the
phone is that they feel like they have
to do their doctor's job sometimes and
so therefore you know your lowers
patients which are assumed to be healthy
if they are not healthy then they are
going to be less satisfied with their
care because they have to do the care
themselves almost they have to figure
out the diagnosis and so he so the
sicker better cared for in that case and
that is what I think attributed to the
surprising results of high-risk patients
already being more likely to respond
positively before we did anything I
would really love to be able to test
this theory somehow but I'm not quite
sure how I would get started but that
would be like my next steps in
continuing this project alright so a
special thanks to my mentor dr. David or
he was wonderful and I'm really sad he
couldn't be here today in grey who have
pretty much worked with even more than
dr. door because this is essentially her
project that I took on as her intern
Katrina Ramsey was our statistician so
she did all of the calculations that I
would need a match in her PhD in math to
do the rest of the cfp team was
wonderful they are always friendly and
willing to answer questions and thanks
to the top med staff the rest of d mice
and I fell
interns you made it a wonderful summer
so any questions or comments yes
oh no it's been used it was developed by
the government I used to have all this
information about when it was developed
exactly one but it's been used we used a
modified version of it that we put it we
picked the questions that we wanted but
this survey has been around for a long
time and is used in many different ways
not just this particular research
project is there anything else about
that okay yes sorry maybe you said this
but was the actual compliance rate with
the survey like how many people like
what percentage of people actually
filled it out actually responded well
for the pre-study we had 45.5 five
percent actually fill it out and return
it and then the post study we had a
little bit less than forty two point
seven five percent
yes it could be a cap survey of been
approved oh that would really good
question i think that the cap survey is
kind of ok so the cap survey that we
used had fork for answers that you could
answer like excellent good pretty good
or like awful but i think if you had
like more choices like six then that
might have changed you might have even
improved given us a more accurate feel
of where exactly that patients are
feeling it instead of four choices if
that makes sense i also feel like some
of the questions could be rewarded a
little bit because I did talk sometimes
over the phone they would ask me to read
the survey and I take the survey over
the phone rather than just asking me
asking them if they wanted another copy
and I would read it to them very slowly
and carefully and they would still be
like wait what does this mean this or
this so it could be clarified different
questions could be clarified in
different ways also
okay that's it thank you
and sometimes it's more important like
especially there's a lot of issues that
people think actually basically
physicians being too free with pain meds
you know because patients just cream you
on the survey so you have to alright
thank you all for being here I'm Joan
ash and this is Lucas Newman he was my
intern for the summer he hails from
Atlanta Georgia and the good news for us
is that I think that we've convinced him
that he really likes Oregon he graduated
from college in June and so he's
available and we're hoping that he will
continue work in this area so that we
can continue working with him so I'll
let you take it from there Lucas
actually worked on two different
projects for me one a VA project and and
one a poet project our research team is
called poet and so he doesn't know it
but now he's a poet ear thank you dr.
Ashe okay and she said I'm Lucas new
moon I'm from Atlanta Georgia I've
worked on a couple projects and the
focus to bring them both in together is
delivering qualitative research results
through the
use of healthcare IT in these projects I
take qualitative research information
and I develop a means to I either
upgrade through a modification of
migrating a side over to a new platform
or I develop a new site or interface for
presenting some newfound research
information I'm from Atlanta Georgia I
have two degrees the first one is
computer information systems from
Griffin tech I have a bachelor's in
biology from Gordon state and I've
worked as a pharmacy technician my
background is mostly IT and pharmacy a
couple of landmarks or imagery to kind
of represent Atlanta I thought of the
CDC and then also the varsity varsity is
pretty popular for burgers and hotdogs
and it's a pretty cool place to check
out in this presentation I'll talk about
a little bit with the qualitative
research and then I'll move into the two
projects that I focused on for the
summer and then I'll conclude and wrap
up so to get started kind of the build
the groundwork on what is qualitative
research there are three major points
and I'll start with the first one
qualitative research is inductive it is
the purpose is to generate theory from
observation it is also oriented to
discovery and exploration rather than
cause and effect with qualitative
research we're not using a predetermined
template or design and this design can
change or evolve over time it's not a
strict framework that you begin with
qualitative research is also subjective
it emphasizes meanings and how they are
interpreted the researcher tries to
understand the perspective of others we
as researchers understand that we are
very vitus in qualitative research it
takes an experienced person to be able
to get close to the data analyze that
information and try not to try to reduce
the bias as much as possible
qualitative research is also contextual
it requires a naturalistic approach with
that researchers it requires researchers
to go out into the field to study and
collect data it is also holistic we are
interested in the complete system rather
than the parts and we will also want to
ask the why questions and then to cover
possible causes and why is the system
acting up what workarounds are we happen
to deal with what warning signs do
physicians have to omit or you know kind
of go by real quick and i'll start with
the kind of move towards my first
project that I worked on with my mentor
dr. ash and this is migrating the CPOE
dorg website the website will to begin
we'll start with a couple of definitions
CPOE is defined as a computer system
that allows direct entry of medical
orders by the person with the license
and privileges to do so and there are
many positives to having electronic
health record system with that allows
the position or provider the to put
entry put information into some of these
positives include reducing unnecessary
variation in care it also ensures that
medications are checked against the
database to prevent adverse drug effects
it also prevents illegible hand written
orders and I'm sure quite a few of you
have seen some chicken scratch around
and about as a pharmacy tech we've had
to diagnose kind of read and call it a
lot of orders that we had received on
paper the the T the poet team the
provider order entry team is a
multidisciplinary team of researchers
and they were led by dr. Joe Nash they
investigated several sites and at these
sites they wanted to uncover the
implications of electronic health record
systems they performed hours upon hours
of observations and interview
interviewed system users
thousands of pages of notes and
transcripts were gathered from these
observations and interviews of
observations interviews and focus groups
a qualitative analysis of data produced
detailed information on the factors
related to success and CPOE and now move
into the to the website that I started
with this is a CPOE website that was
originally designed and implemented in
the year 2000 by poet and the goal of
this website is to produce or provide
access to a collection of CPOE resources
and links and these resources include
types of unintended consequences means
of getting around or avoiding unattended
adverse consequences in electronic
health record systems systems and
technical information for rolling out
and then also the recommendations for
evaluating or measuring the success of
your CPU rollout and to do this to bring
it over to the new system or the new
platform originally started with the the
original site that was developed in 2000
which is a my sequel PHP set and then I
use the common spot tools which is
common or used for ohsu dot edu and by
taking the information plugging it in
and moving it over I'm able to bring it
over to ohsu edu under a similar
template so it looks clean it's relevant
with the the rest of the school website
and also it has long-term update support
as Hsu edu gets updated this shares that
same template and design and it's not
continue to be on the one that was from
10 years ago and I'd like to move into
the second research project and this one
is the VA focus we were working with the
VA on this particular project and the
principal investigators are dr. mark
elfin and dr. Joe Nash
and this is a pilot project the goal
this one was to create a library of
patient narratives related to the social
integration of after traumatic brain
injury and diabetes diagnosis
researchers can use the library that
developed that we develop to better
understand patient priorities and health
care needs and on this we use to gather
information we use a series of
semi-structured interviews we also we
audio and video recorded those with the
permission from the patient and then we
also took these videos and transcripts
and the goal is to put them on a single
database that researchers can access the
goal or the goal that we're working
towards the model that we're using is
health talk online org and what he'll
talk online is is it's a site develop a
UK health experience research group and
it's supported by DX charity it's a
collection of patient narratives on over
50 illnesses and health conditions and
they're all linked on one online
database as you can see here they list
out the several major sections for
different health disorders and then you
can go through and navigate and pick the
specific diagnosis or disease and then
you can watch personal videos that are
public for anyone to watch and it's a
great resource for clinicians and
patients alike and with this this is
kind of the setup that I was using for
developing a the mock website I kind of
did a little bit of background research
and I tried to figure out what platform
we could potentially use at the VA and
so I developed our web module around
what what we could use to roll out over
there so I started out with the Oracle
VirtualBox i installed ubuntu server on
that I made a live Drupal installation
added content developed a template
developed the theme and then what I did
is I went in and saved each page and
then I what I could do
in k which is an advanced text editor as
able to load up all the files that wants
and make changes and the goal of doing
all this work was so that we can have a
portable version of our template we
could burn it on a blank CD or throw it
on a USB drive we can mail it over to
Britain to show to help talk online we
could share this this template and show
our ideas and what this does is you know
you plug it in double click on it and
you have what is our modules the modules
kind of similar to what he'll talk
online uses is you click on a major
category for a disease and then you kind
of hone in say we want to look at
traumatic brain injury and then under
TBI we have a list of headings and from
those headings you can pick specific
videos you can watch a specific
experience that one patient has and
contrast it to another and it's a really
a really invaluable resource that we're
trying to build for researchers to see
and then they can adjust healthcare
needs accordingly to what the interests
of the patients and over the summer I
learned a quite a few things coming in I
only had a perception of bioinformatics
with with the summer internship I've had
the wonderful opportunity to work with
dr. ash and I learned of several other
interests in informatics those in
particular being in clinical medical I
had also an opportunity to work with dr.
Hirsch and dr. mcqueeney on a grant
application for NIH and that was a big
project and it took a lot of work and it
was it was a great experience to learn
how that process takes place to get a
research it's a start research I also
learned how to use a common spot which
is a content management system not too
unlike Drupal of this particular one is
has a different back-end and different
things that make it tick ohsu website
development I learned the process of
rolling out a website on a wage issue
and the web help group was very very
helpful any issues I had they helped me
right away with those also learned about
VA website development deployment when I
developed this template or this mock
module for the website I tried to
construct it in the means of how the VA
could roll a particular project like
this out I learned about the way to
issue an internal review board IRB in
their policies as also the VA to
different organizations of two very
different structures and being able to
work with both of those kind of allowed
me to get an idea of you know handling a
variety of different projects but under
different organizations I'd also like to
thank dr. Joe Nash my mentor she's been
great helped me out whenever I needed it
it's been awesome to come out here to
Oregon to work on these projects dr.
mark helfen who was unable to make it
here today he's the p.i for the VA
personal narratives library also on that
team doc dr. Erica Cottrell Lauren and
Eric and I'd like to think Todd who
helped me set up the new CPOE template
on a common spot and D mice and my
fellow interns any questions yes yes is
the new bullet site life it's not live
yet because I helped out with a couple
other different projects the start date
on that got moved back within within two
to three weeks the new new switch will
be flipped and the new site will be up
and running it's just a matter of
getting the pages up and then the domain
linking that over all right any other
questions
yes oh sorry have you did they have
requirements about making them
accessible like did you also have to
have transcripts or audio only or any
sort of requirements like that well with
this project currently it's isolated to
researchers now with the videos
themselves it's video audio and
transcripts and what the goal is to have
all that accessible depending on the the
patients once if they want the video
public or for researchers if they want
the video or just audio or just a
transcript we would definitely give them
that option and the any other questions
oh thank you
Oh
me now it's my pleasure to introduce
kevin bein line kevin as the intern
who's been working with me this summer
he's well he's from portland but goes to
Santa Clara University where he's a
rising junior in computer science and
engineering I gave Kevin a really
difficult problem because it's a very
poorly structured problem having which
he'll explain to you but unstructured
problems are sometimes our biggest
challenges both in medicine and
informatics so he's going to tell you
about some explorations he did for me
this summer to help make some progress
and give it some structure right come
okay so as dr. Gorman said I kind of
dealt with a problem that is at least 20
agency there are very few places that do
what i was exploring well by any means
and so that's why i can't with the title
about challenges a curriculum mapping
medical education Oh a little bit about
me I mean he said I'm porn Oregon which
is I'm thinking from the Good Sam and
third year Peter science and engineering
major which I get all that questions
about so I thought I would do a little
bit of explanation about what that is
and it's a blend of software and
hardware as you may or may not be able
to figure out and as I was able to find
out it they describe it as including
introduction and high-level programming
there's some logic design and chip
architecture computer architecture and a
number of different embassies that are
not quite theoretical computer science
but not quite hardware Electrical
Engineering base sort of a nice blend so
the outline I their couple a couple of
motivating scenarios that all outline
and a problem statement which I derive
from that and then the number of
approaches that I took to explore how to
improve on what agency you frankly
doesn't do very well which is not a lot
but in this case it doesn't do something
very well and then a couple of takeaways
and knowledge mints so a problem with
computers and human language is that
computers deal with data and very strict
rule sets I mean humans deal with data
as well but we deal with communication
and expression on a very complicated
convoluted level which sometimes I think
we take for granted and the answer to
when will my computer understand me is a
good one because computer is I mean
human language is very complex and some
people might argue beautifully complex
but it's really expressive only for
humans computers don't really understand
structure human structure and it's very
difficult for them to quantify it and
make it something that they're able to
process and handle so machine language
is what they would I I mean I would call
it their cup of tea computers like to
deal with zeros and ones and stuff that
instructions such a way that they can
process it and that's not really what
human language comes in I mean
programming languages are a form of
making the bridge between computers and
humans less obvious but again this is
not what human language looks like
thankfully because this is pretty
limited in terms of what it can do at
least on the surface so in comparison
human expression this is a picture of
Shakespeare's plays or some of his plays
is incredibly I mean it has a structure
so it's not really proper to call it
unstructured but it has a structure in
such a way that a computer can't by
nature understand how to read the human
form of structure and process the words
in such a way that you know it's able to
find a specific word or find a concept
or know any of the parts of speech or
anything that we apply to human language
to make it comprehensible to us they
don't understand any of that by nature I
mean we can give them that ability but
again it's a difficult problem so
there's two scenarios that we kind of
there are a couple others but two
scenarios that we tried to focus on in
dealing with curriculum mapping and the
first one is a student and they may have
for instance an exam on as pick a topic
pain and they want to study thoroughly
which is hopefully what they want to do
and so by traditional methods they might
have a hard time finding all the
material that they want at least get
quality material and with data being
created at such a high rate these days
on an exponential scale it's just going
to get worse and humans are not nearly
as quick and and capable of finding
things as computers are but computers
also can't understand our language by
nature so we have to solve that problem
and by traditional methods it would take
this is a rhetorical question but about
traditional methods it would take an
incredibly long time for a human to go
through the equivalent amount of
material that computer be able to go
through in seconds and it especially
given all the other demands that we have
in our lives today this is kind of a
funny picture of what some of us might
imagine a late night at the library and
then the other scenario that we dealt
with was a faculty professor that
perhaps is visiting maybe they're fairly
new here and they're teaching in ethics
and they don't really know the how the
system works they don't really know the
curriculum and they won
find out where the other students are in
terms of their understanding of ethics
or whatever branch of ethics that
they're teaching in particular and I
guess another rhetorical question you
could ask for the situation is how much
would they be able to find out without
knowing the ohsu sort of environment and
being able to access materials that
would tell them what they want to know
in terms of comprehension by the
students that they're going to teach
they don't want to teach the same thing
over again and potential sources syllabi
slides readings I even thought of course
evaluations and this picture illustrates
is in a cartoonish way it's kind of what
we're looking at especially with so much
data being generated these days we have
to look in so many different places and
it takes so much more time than a
computer would but again the problem is
getting a computer to understand our
language and language structure in the
first place so how can curriculum
mapping help Ricky mapping in general
from what I could tell was sort of
classified as a tool for more
administrative types and people higher
up in an educational setting that would
use it to identify big gaps or strengths
in their curriculum and not necessarily
for the two examples that I just gave
where you have like a student or a
professor and they want to find out
where something is in the curriculum and
they want to use the other to study or
to figure out where their communities
that they're going to be speaking to is
that in terms of understanding it's not
necessarily made for that so an idea as
an as an end concept would be to make an
interface that would cater to the
administrative types but also be able to
benefit people wanting to do an average
say Google search of the material which
again is a very complicated problem so
as I mentioned curriculum mapping is a
very difficult task it
Will's do do it on a certain level but
I'm usually in a very topical level just
indexing the course names the slide
titles and that kind of thing which is
not very rich in terms of what it's
accessing there's a lot of stuff that's
hidden in a slide in the slides or in a
reading that may not be obvious from the
surface title and so how the question is
how we can leverage natural language
processing or NLP techniques to make the
curricula material quickly and
comprehensively searchable so I took a
number of approaches when evaluating
like what options ohs you might have for
developing a an end application for use
in the in the school I first took one
only one of many sheets of Excel
objectives from the old old medical
school curriculum and after receiving
the output plugging into these different
programs and receiving the output I took
the input and either adjusted the input
text itself or the parameters to make it
or make the output more desirable to
what we were looking for make it more
readable is some of these programs
they'll make their output very readable
and then I quickly pretty quickly
generated out opinions about how this
may or may not be useful for OA chess
use these and this is an example of a
lab the objectives defined by one of the
labs 4g for the gie section of the
curriculum and this is clearly human
plain text but again it it's as
displayed in an Excel document that
commuter doesn't necessarily know how to
deal with this deal with the structure
and deal with the typos and regularities
of human language that we take for
granted but the computer doesn't really
know how to deal with first sort of
group of programs are dealt with or
standalone program
they're generally very sparse these are
just a few examples of the kind of
programs that are out there the main one
I dealt with was mallet and these
programs deal with the each command
prompt a lot which is not very
user-friendly I actually had some
trouble trying to understand
documentation they're not very nice to
look at not really what we're looking
for in the end but they even though I
ran into difficulty with them they could
be useful for someone with more
knowledge I'm not very experienced in
these tools to begin with so they would
be used for something like a mash-up and
bringing different resources together to
make an application not just be able to
do it all by themselves they're not
specific either to medical text they're
just not there just general programs
second group of programs I dealt with
we're from the National Library of
medicines United a unified medical
language system which is includes a meth
asaurus of medical vocabularies a
semantic network to link things together
and then a number of tools to help you
do it's a natural language processing
and this is a very nice free actually
tool for at least four US citizens you
have to get a license to use their tools
but it's free and I got it I got my
license right away which is nice and you
can use it however eat like my initial
approach was to use meta map which is
again another command prompt base
program which is hosted locally on your
machine and but I ran again into
problems with the command problems they
got areas that I couldn't quite figure
out so thankfully i stumbled upon these
batch tools that they made and post it
online and allow you to use their own
servers and systems to use meta map
which recognizes you and less concepts
Sam rap which recognizes subject up
the creation object ripples and mpi
which summarizes text into mesh terms I
mostly dealt with meta map which is what
I originally tried but this is in a
different form with an easier to use
interface those more user-friendly and
the other two I use but their output was
much more difficult to understand and
not as clear as meta map all the meta
map had its own problems and as I say
down below meta map well it had a nice
interface along with the other ones it
had quite a few unexplained options that
could have helped us refine the output
and make it more we wanted but we're
unexplained and someone that's
uninitiated which would be me or anyone
else that is not an expert or has used
this program a lot would have a hard
time understanding in terms of what
would benefit them and then simmer up an
NPI while they provided fewer options
their output was less obviously readable
it may it may be more useful to someone
that can study the documentation and
really understand it but it was less
obviously useful than the meta Maps
output this is an example the outfit
that i got from part only a small part
of the lab objectives that i posted no
I'm few slides ago the this part and
it's doing a processing of these five
words right here and one of the main
problems with meta map is that it
generates a huge amount of output so
again even though there are a lot of
options that can really figure out how
that sort of bring things down and make
it more easily readable and it's for
instance at the top it's taking five
words cutting out some of the
unnecessary bits and then generating
umls concepts and linking them with
their
unique IDs and it doesn't always work
very nicely it would prefer that the
tech the input tax be in a certain
manner to make things better but this is
just an example of the kind of output I
got probably one of the better examples
this is this is an example of all the
options that had when using meta map
only the ones that have the question
marks and blue circles were explained at
all again I new to this material so well
I could figure out some just by what
they used it to to describe them there
wasn't further documentation to see like
how other ones may affect it and well I
was able to do some parenting down again
there's a lot of stuff that I didn't
quite understand which even though I had
a contact at the National Library of
Medicine even he couldn't help me a
hundred percent so an example knowledge
map was a third of sort of approach that
I took and it's a program that
Vanderbilt adults in the early 2000s at
lisas the period that I think they
developed it it's kind of hard to tell
based on the documentation and it's a
course management and indexing service
they developed the medical school which
is sounded pretty much like what ohsu
wanted or what we want and so I looked
into it thankfully I was a they were
nice enough to give us access and even
though they're phasing it out and moving
to a new system called v star which is
much nicer it still seemed to fulfill a
purpose and this is a condyle is just an
example of one of the searches that I
did and how it marks the text to show
you it is this little blue arrow which
is not very obvious but on the previous
screen it will show you all the
documents that have hits for whatever
just whatever Cara is that you search
for and then it all
mark them if you click on the document
with the blue arrow which is pointed out
and my impression is that it's closer to
what we want and it makes things more
readable it displays the documents the
way you would generally the way you
would be them in a word processor but
it's also like not at least this
particular version i don't know about v
star which is more full-featured this
knowledge map is being phased out so i
don't know if it's quite what we're
looking for if we'd even be able to use
e star which is more more more
comprehensive learning management
management system which also has this
functionality but is what they're
focusing more the resources on so i
don't know this would be exactly what
we're looking for although it is much
more polished and promising than either
the other two approaches which would
require more development and
implementation costs versus this which
we like you likely would have to pay for
which is not unexpected but if this
ended up being what we wanted to go with
it would save us development and
development costs in terms of having to
make our own application and interface
versus something that's already been
developed and Vanderbilt's a hotbed for
this kind of thing so they know what
they're doing i'm a few of the takeaways
ohsu is not not very good at this whole
curriculum mapping thing they do some
limited mapping of the again like slide
titles and some very topical stuff but
not the not the real like me d sections
of getting into the slides looking at
readings stuff that may be obscured by
just looking at the title is as has been
used the number of times there isn't
necessarily a class about the
stethoscope but it's everywhere if you
wanted to learn about it you wouldn't
necessarily be able to find it just by
what they're doing already
so there's two approaches at which you
can do they could build a mash-up which
would take more development and resource
there be more costs involved with that
and it would be time consuming whether
it was done here by a third party or
they could if it's even possible we have
not completely explored the avenue of
getting an outside program to help us
with this content indexing service and
what we do have elios which is the
content management system there is not a
whole lot of this content or concept
mapping curriculum mapping being able to
dig into the content so where if a
student want to look for a given subject
to be able to find it in this slideshow
that reading this syllabus whatever it
is they want to and it's not necessarily
covered by the topical just the title
the slide or something like that the
notes or whatever it is this is tricky
and mapping the idea is to make things
much more richly available and to allow
people to use it did you I guess my my
concept that the final product would be
sort of like it it's something that is
at Google like interface or they'd be
able to ask questions of the content and
be able to get their answers and be able
to tell specifically where it is like
which slide it's on be able to tell more
than just the title will give them final
thing is if either these approaches is
what we're going with then it's going to
take resources of a certain kind time
more time for the mash-up also
development costs for that but if we go
a third party or the outside
institutions work then there's also
going to be cost with that in terms of
I'm sure licensing and all of that
which is not my department
acknowledgments ohsu for having a whole
bus dr. pol gone my mentor buck Melissa
handle who helped us early on and gave
us the impetus to look into meta map
which she knew more about Nathan bearer
who is our contact the NLM helped us out
a little bit and then dr. Joshua Denny
dr. Anderson's Picard and Peter spouts
who were sort of contacts at Vanderbilt
to help us out with knowledge map and
the problems that we actually ran into
with that and also my fellow interns
that's it no the hours later one
question any we have time for
alright now we weren't dealing with what
the examples of stuff that would be
useful for people like slides and notes
and readings and that we were dealing
with one I dealt with one sheet of an
Excel document that contained objectives
listed objectives for the labs and
courses within a certain part of the
curriculum that's what we dealt with for
this test the idea is to expand that
obviously two slides and readings and
all the other course material that's out
there and is only going to grow and
making it more accessible by computer
okay thanks everyone